hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my vixen episode 5 video and just a
heads up next week will be the last
episode of vixen there's only six
episodes then the week after that flash
and arrow come back they haven't said
anything officially but Marc Guggenheim
did say that the voice actress may :
might make it to the live-action shows
now I think if it's successful enough
they'll just continue doing vixen and
she'll also guest star on the
live-action shows but at the very least
she'll probably guest star on flash and
arrow at some point so here we go
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet this episode all about vixen
learning her origin story somebody else
giving you your own origin story that
seems like a funny idea and we get the
big revealed that this person trying to
take the totem from her is her sister
what's going on here is like the
sympathetic villain monologue where it's
like look at what's happened here I need
to make it better please give me the
totem so that I can do that but
underneath their breath you get a whiff
of well I just I want more power gimme
gimme gimme
based on the events of the flashback I
do think this character is her sister I
don't think that she's lying about that
I think her mother just bolted but I do
think she's being intentionally
misleading about being the true guardian
of the totem I was meant to be the
guardian of the totem until her mother
ran away with you the thing that they've
changed from the comics they changed her
backstory just a little bit vixens
entire family ends up getting killed by
poachers she flees to America she comes
back later and finds out that it was
actually her uncle that was the poacher
that killed her family trying to take
the totem so they've changed things to
make the battle for the totem much more
personal like it's very believable that
you would fight with your sister over
something like that over a family
heirloom of power and because it was
other hunters that killed their father
it makes her a more sympathetic villain
I wasn't powerful enough to protect our
village I could have used the totem to
stop what happened so when the sister is
talking about responsibility to the dead
she's talking about their dead father
it's like you have two sisters that are
shaped by a single event like a single
trauma in the past one swings super dark
and the other vixen swings too good so
I'm totally cool with them changing her
backstory from the comics just to make a
little more meaningful thematically the
relationships between family members is
actually gonna be a big plot point
during arrow season for this year so
just just wait for that especially with
the villain damian darhk-- pretty much
everything else about the episode is
comic-book accurate
the reason the sister is able to take
the totem from her at the end is be
she's so close to death I mean obviously
she's not gonna die she's not gonna die
before the last episode of her series
especially if she's gonna go on the
live-action show but now the conflict is
all about vixen reclaiming her heritage
getting the totem back so she can start
her future because the totem is her
future the vixen persona is what's
coming she can't do that till she gets
the totem back and if you remember at
the beginning of the episode she's like
I'm happy to get rid of this I just want
to know wTF is going on with my family
so that's what the final episode is
gonna be is like her coming to the
realization that the totem is a part of
her her history and that she needs it
back my favorite moment in the episode
though it was just that funny reaction
when she's sitting there in the crouched
running stance and her sister implies
that she's gonna have to kill her to get
the totem back and she's just like peace
I'm out of here
buddy she runs out a frame that's one of
the things I like about cartoons that
live-action shows can't necessarily do I
mean Barry could run out of frame like
that but it's just there are certain
comedic beats that you can hit with an
animated show that you can't do with
live-action so I'd be totally happy if
they greenlit a vixen series of its
State animated just as long as they did
more episodes and they made a longer let
me know in the comments though how do
you feel about the tone of vixen
compared to other DC animated shows like
Teen Titans or Young Justice really like
anything animated do you want it to be a
little bit sillier do you want it to be
a little more straight-up like the old
Teen Titans show so the really big news
now is that heroes reborn is starting on
Thursday so you're probably watching
this video on Thursday right now so this
afternoon should be new heroes I'll
totally be doing videos there's gonna be
13 episodes total so be sure to
subscribe to get everything if you
haven't started watching it yet either
you need to check out Doctor Who because
it's actually a pretty badass this
season if you guys didn't see my court
of owls video you can click here to
learn all about how Gotham is doing
Batman court of owls and you can click
here for my flash season 2 trailer with
a whole bunch of jay garrick footage
thank you so much watching everybody
let's have five I'll see you guys
tonight